alright I'm going to talk about
violating one field theory it's
something I've worked on for a few years
with Stephen Jordan and keep Lee and I
know you you thought you were going to
have lunch now and instead you you're
having me for lunch so also this is the
last talked and it's Saturday so I'm not
going to try to tell you very technical
things I want to give you an idea of why
we think this problem is interesting
what's been done so far what we hope to
do so why do we care about simulating
quantum field theory on quantum computer
it's because quantum field theory is
really the basis underlying almost
everything in physics a possible
exception being quantum gravity but
everything else we know about the
fundamental interactions and all the
physics built on that including atomic
physics in condensed matter physics is
founded on quantum field theory so this
is really in cards motivated by the big
question about the quantum church Turing
thesis is it true that anything that
occurs in nature can be efficiently
simulated with the general purpose
Universal quantum computer and the
question is one of those fortunate ones
in which either the yes answer or the no
answer would be exciting so if the
answer is yes
then it means that with a quantum
computer we should be able to simulate
any process that can occur in the
physical world something that we don't
think is possible with ordinary
classical digital computers so that's an
important application and we can imagine
that in the future when we have
large-scale quantum computers they will
be used by physicists and also chemists
and engineers to study such problems if
the answer is no I guess from a
fundamental physics point of view that
is the exciting answer it means that
there are processes in nature that we
can't simulate with the model of quantum
computation we're currently using in
some sense the computational resources
that nature allows have not been fully
captured by the model of universal
quantum computers we're currently using
and so even more powerful computation
may be allowed by the laws of physics
now I'm really talking about digital
quantum simulation that is simulations
that we could do in the future if we
have scalable fault tolerant quantum
computers I make the distinction between
digital and analog quantum simulation
analog quantum simulation is a very
active area currently both theoretically
and experimentally many people are using
cold systems of atoms and optical
lattices systems of molecules ion traps
that can be customized so that we can
adjust of with knobs that we have
control of in the laboratory the
interactions among particles and so
study different types of local
hamiltonians and do experiments to
observe the properties of the system
that theme is limited by the imperfect
control that people have over the system
so actually they're interesting
complexity theoretic questions about our
such simulations really giving us
information about a problem which is
classically computationally hard which I
think are open questions but anyway
that's not what I'm talking about i'm
going to imagine that i have a quantum
computer that can do logical gates on
logical qubits with whatever accuracy i
need as we envision will be the case
when we use the principles of fault
tolerance in scalable quantum computers
of the future so a digital quantum
simulation really has three steps
there's a state preparation that we do
to get things started that is keen our
quantum computer preparing some quantum
state which describes the ideal system
that we want to simulate and then we
simulate the sherer evolution with some
local hamiltonian i'll just say well
write e to the minus IHT meaning a time
evolution operator though i don't
necessarily want to restrict my
attention to a time independent amal
tonian it might actually be a
time-dependent hamiltonian and then we
perform some kind of simulated
measurement of something which is
computationally reasonable like
measuring some local observable and the
task we're trying to perform is to
sample with reasonable accuracy from the
probability distribution of outcomes of
that final measurement maybe with some
error but with some sufficiently small
error and we're interested in how do the
resources scale with various things like
the error if we have a good simulation
we desire that the resources that we
need will scale reasonably polynomial e
with the air with things like the total
system size and also with the energy of
the process so what I mean by resources
of course are essentially space and time
we're interested in the number of qubits
we need to do the simulation and the
number of gates and we hope they will
scale polynomial e with one over epsilon
where epsilon is some measure of the
year and things like the particle number
the total energy of the process and
maybe other physical measures so you
might say isn't this really a solved
problem I'm not sure whether it's been
discussed in the boot camp but already
in the 1990s Seth Lloyd and others
discuss how we can simulate a local
Hamiltonian but we have Hamiltonian
which can be written as a sum of terms
each of which is K local
study acting collectively non-trivial
Aeon in most KQ bits and has a norm it's
a an operator norm bounded above by some
constant and then at least for the
evolution part of the problem the claim
is that there's some simulated unitary
evolution operator we want it to be
close to the ideal evolution that we're
trying to simulate governed by this
Hamiltonian so in sum norm let's say the
operator norm we want this to be less
than Epsilon we can take that to be a
measure of the air and you know it's a
no result for a while that this can be
done with a number of gates which is
polynomial in a 1 over epsilon and in
what I'll call Omega which is if we're
thinking of a geometrically local
Antonia is the space-time volume that
we're trying to simulate so its volume
times time um
so why isn't the problem solved well for
one thing we're interested in
hamiltonians which are in some sense
local but for which it's not necessarily
the case that the terms in the
Hamiltonian have a founded norm so
they're local now not in the sense so
that's necessarily acting on some
founded number of qubits but rather we
have some other decomposition into
degrees of freedom each one x on some
bounded number of degrees of freedom but
the Hamiltonian may have terms which are
infinite norm but they're the more
fundamental problem really is that even
if we're trying to simulate a finite
spatial volume the Hamiltonian is an
infinite sum there's a number of degrees
of freedom per unit volume which is
infinite so we have a system with the
number of qubits per volume which is
infinite what's characteristic of
quantum field theory is that there are
degrees of freedom at arbitrarily
shortwave line so that if I have a
thimble full of space that I'm trying to
sing light do people still speak about
thimbles to talk about something small I
guess you have to I took sewing class in
seventh grade it's a simple some a
little thing that little volume you try
to simulate it well the thing is if
there really an infinite number of
degrees freedom in there because you
have to consider arbitrarily short
wavelengths and if we needed to simulate
accurately all of those degrees of
freedom it would be it would be hopeless
even simulating a finite volume would
require infinite resources but the good
news is that corresponding to shorter
and shorter wavelengths are higher and
higher energy so although all those
degrees of freedom are in some sense
there we have to include energy in our
resource
counting and if we consider abounded
energy we won't really have to simulate
with very good accuracy the extremely
short distance physics because those
degrees of freedom are going to be very
unlikely to get excited so the idea is
the short wavelengths I don't have to be
accurately simulated
if we have some bounded energy and
that's going to make our tests possible
and actually this is thus a really
important principle not just for the
purpose of trying to do a computer
simulation of the system it you could
say in some sense it's the most
important idea in all of physics that if
we want to understand physics at long
distances let's say at the scale of a
hydrogen atom we don't have to get right
all the microscopic details of quantum
gravity at a scale of 10 to the minus 35
meters and we don't have to know all
about that short distance physics to
understand the long distance physics and
you know if it weren't for that physics
wouldn't be possible we could never we
could never understand the Bohr atom
without doing quantum gravity how would
we get started but we really can
decompose the world kind of scale by
scale and understand one scale at a time
that's how physics has progressed and we
use the same principle and trying to
simulate the system we can study its low
energy physics without simulating it's
very short distance physics with good
accuracy so this is this is a good news
bad news thing it means like I said that
we can do with Tomic physics without
understanding physics at the Planck
scale it also means that it's really
hard saying bye doing experiments at the
Large Hadron Collider or maybe we can
explore physics at the ten to the minus
19 metre scale then be pretty hard to
learn about physics at the Planck scale
which is 10 to the minus 35 meters
because the physics that the low
energies is not very sensitive at all to
the physics at very short distances now
beyond quantum field theory things get
interesting in a way ultimately we'd
like to be able to think about
simulating processes in which quantum
fluctuations in space
time are important quantum gravity and
then we won't necessarily have a
geometrically local Hamiltonian to talk
about in fact the whole concept of
space-time may be in some sense and
emergent concept for some more
fundamental underlying theory but it
still may be reasonable to hope that we
can think of the Hamiltonian of being k
local not necessarily geometrically
local in some dimension but having amel
tonian that can be decomposed into
pieces which each of which act on a
bounded number of degrees of freedom and
then a simulation may still be feasible
even with a general-purpose quantum
computer ok so I'm going to talk about
relativistic quantum field theories I
mean it's it's also interesting to talk
about nonrelativistic ones but
relativistic theories are the ones that
we use in particle physics there in some
sense the most fundamental because we
think that Lawrence and variance is a
fundamental feature of space-time and so
on a quantum computer what we're going
to do is choose a Hamiltonian and try to
simulate the evolution described by the
Hamiltonian which means we have to do
something which is kind of disgusting
from the point of view of the
relativistically invariant theory we
have to pick a reference frame pick a
particular way of defining time and then
evolve using a Hamiltonian appropriate
for that way of slicing up the
space-time into time slices and some
other observer might prefer to slice up
space time in a different way and would
use maybe a different Hamiltonian but it
doesn't matter because if they compare
their answers for questions when the
answers can be formulated in a way that
doesn't depend on the reference frame
they'll agree with one another so we
just pick some particular frame and
describe the Hamiltonian evolution in
that frame now how do we formulate
Theory the observables are filled
so their functions of space time so i'm
going to write Phi of X and PI of X
which are the field and it's conjugate
momentum so here X represents a
coordinate of a point in space i'm going
to use little d to denote the dimension
of space and so for each value of the
real coordinates of a point in
space-time there's a corresponding
operator and all the 5 x's are mutually
commuting for different values of x or
the same value of x that commute
themselves so if i consider at some
fixed time the commutator of phi of x
width x why it's 0 so they can all be
simultaneously diagonalized and there
are also conjugate momentum which are
mutually commuting one for each spatial
point but the thighs and the pies have a
non-trivial commutation relation equal
to i times a d-dimensional delta
function of the difference i'm using
units in which H bar and C has been
conveniently set equal to 1 and so this
is just like the canonical commutation
relations for a particle and a potential
a commutator of a position and momentum
but now we have this formally infinite
number of p's and q's which we have a
field for each point in space and the
hamiltonian that will consider can be
written as an integral over D
dimensional space of a polynomial in the
fields square of the field momentum plus
a square how to put an effect or
one-half here I guess plus a square with
the coefficient well actually I want to
put in the gradients of the fields the
great answer the fee
squared plus some parameter with the
dimensions of mass x squared and then
plus a parameter I'll call lambda fourth
power of five and that's going to be the
Hamiltonian I'd like to consider and
zero squared is called the bear mass
because we want to emphasize it is it
doesn't necessarily correspond to the
physical masses of particles described
by the theory and if we didn't have this
last term the quartic term then this
would be a very simple theory to solve
it would be what we call a Gaussian
theory of free field theory and we
essentially can calculate everything you
want to know about it analytically so it
makes the problem interesting is this
term what it corresponds to one once we
quantize the theory the theory describes
particles and if we didn't have the
nonlinear term or the non quadratic term
in the Hamiltonian then the particles
would just be non interacting so become
essentially a one particle theory what
makes it an interesting many particle
theory is that this term describes
particle collisions of two particles
when they occupy the same point in
space-time interact in a non-trivial way
and that's what makes the problem
potentially hard and interesting to
simulate so just to make sure the
notation is clear if i wanted to i could
write down a wave function for the
system and i could expand it in terms of
some basis and as a basis i can choose a
complete set of commuting operators like
the fields themselves and so i could
expand the wave function as a functional
integral over all functions of space
some amplitude and a state Phi sorry the
notations a little bit schematic but
this means a simultaneous eigen state of
all the 5 x's
which are continuously you know burying
infinite number and that's a basis for
the hilbert space we can expand any say
in terms of it so just stop since I
suppose not all of you were physicists
I'll give you a history lesson so
quantum field theory has its origins in
the 1920s not long after quantum
mechanics was developed those were the
days when Giants roaming the earth great
physicist where it work Dirac Heisenberg
poly born and Jordan were all founders
of quantum field theory around 1927 and
one of the things they did right away as
they realized while you could take the
the free part of the theory they were
thinking of the electromagnetic field at
the time and you can quantize that and
understand everything about it and what
it describes his photons particles of
light and that provided kind of a
fundamental point of view on the light
quantum hypothesis which had been
proposed 22 years earlier by Einstein
but then confusion reigned for about 20
years because people started using
quantum field theory to compute things
and you can compute in a perturbation
expansion in this parameter and that
worked really well in electrodynamics if
you computed just to the first
non-trivial order of perturbation theory
the leading term in a power series
expansion and the coupling constant but
when you try to go beyond that leading
order perturbation theory it blew up in
your face and gave infinite answers
which caused great consternation and
confusion and let people that suggests
there's something wrong with quantum
mechanics or there's something wrong
with this formalism of quantum field
theory and it got straightened out
conceptually in the late 40s by Fineman
tominaga schwinger Dyson and what they
realized is you
have to be very sure that you're
thinking about the theory in operational
terms if you want to use this theory to
compute some physical process that can
be an observed and experiment the
calculations you should do should relate
different quantities which can be
observed in the experiment it would be
wrong these people said to just try to
compute say electron electron scattering
the probability or cross section for
electron electron scattering in terms of
the parameters of Hamiltonian if those
parameters can't be directly observed in
the experiment what we should do instead
is express the answer for electron
electron scattering in terms of other
directly experimentally measurable
quantities like the mass of the electron
and the charge of the electron and when
you did that properly it works and you
really get sensible answers too sensible
physical questions these infinities drop
up although it was a non-trivial
combinatorial task performed mostly by
Dyson to show that that really worked
and then there was a period in the 50s
which I guess I won't tell you about the
details of this part because I'm already
on burning time at an astonishing rate
but where people started to worry about
what what is a quantum field theory from
some sort of mathematically rigorous
point of view white men in the mid-50s
formulated a set of axioms which became
by consensus what a quantum field theory
was and then that gave rise to the
challenge can we mathematically really
construct one in some you know
mathematically well-defined way show
that quantum field theory exists and
well that is still from a mathematicians
point of view an unfinished program but
the key insight that I think answered to
the satisfaction of most physicists what
is a quantum field theory
from Ken Wilson in the 1960s great
physicists just passed away this a few
months ago and it's very interesting how
this happened because Wilson was rather
unusual back in the 60s among physicists
because he was very interested in
computation and he really knew a lot
about computers and code and he started
to ask himself suppose I wanted to do
quantum field theory on a computer how
would I do that how would I set up the
problem and of course he realized that
as nothing you know this was a great
insight but as with any attempt to put a
continuous medium on a computer you got
to digitize it so you'll have to somehow
approximate the system by one with a
finite number of degrees of freedom so
we'd like to put our theory on the
lattice in space with some lattice
spacing so what i wrote formally as an
integral we should really think of as
being a sum over the sites of some
lattice and now there's a field variable
living at each one of the sites and if
we want to describe what we really want
to describe though is the quote unquote
continuum limit of the theory in which
we can remove this short distance cutoff
so we want to take the limit of a going
to zero and how do you do that exactly
and Wilson kind of turn this on its head
and he said well really we should think
about it this way we have some fixed
lattice and what we're interested in is
for the physics that we want to study
becoming very long distance in units of
the lattice spacing so what we want to
study is in particular if in the unit
i'm using a mass is the same thing as an
inverse length so the particles have
masses we want their inverse masses to
get much larger than the lattice spacing
we want all the energy scales to get
much larger than the lattice spacing and
really so this so-called
the one that is what a condensed matter
physicists would call a second order
phase transition it means the
correlation length of the problem in all
the relevant physics is becoming
arbitrarily long distance compared to
the fixed lattice spacing and what makes
this a very powerful observation which
is what Wilson realize is that for the
purpose of describing that very long
distance physics you don't need to know
much about the microscopic theory the my
tits this same idea that I mentioned
before really about the short distance
physics it not being necessary to
simulate in detail but this is really
Wilson's key idea this Hamiltonian might
be very complicated it might have lots
of other parameters that I didn't write
down but for the purpose of calculating
physics at very long distances compared
to the lattice spacing we don't need to
know all those microscopic details
everything we need to know can be
encoded in just a small number of
parameters and that was really the right
way of looking at what we call
renormalize ability how we can make
sense of the theory when the lattice
spacing is very small compared to
physical length scales and incidentally
Wilson had another question
it sounds as if you're saying well there
was a discretization issue and might if
you take care of the citation issue
everything which is for science face it
you know we never expected well with the
worry would have been that even when you
go to long distances there are still an
indefinite number of parameters from the
short distance theory which govern what
the long distance physics is life it can
happen yet it can happen so that's
really the difference between what we
mean by a renormalize achill theory and
a non-normal logical theory in the case
of the non-normalized able theories the
physics at long distances can be
sensitive to the very short distance
physics well but but Wilson I mean
Wilson looked at this the right way
which is the way you're looking at it so
that the answer is obvious because
before people we're trying to you know
understand here's the theory and now
let's try to go to higher and higher and
higher energies and see how the very
high energy processes depend on the
parameters of the theory and that's
that's how they encountered all these
infinities and what the infinities were
signaling is that if the theory isn't
were normalizable you need more and more
and more free parameters to calculate to
higher and higher and higher accuracy
but if you look at the reddit the right
way which is that you're really looking
at a very long distance limit of some
fixed theory it's easier to understand
why only a small number of parameters
would
relevant for making the low energy
predictions okay yeah you you see theory
what does that have a precise meaning
theory has a precise meaning it means in
the context of this discussion a
particular Hamiltonian yeah so we have
you know a standard model for particle
physics you can think of that as just a
Hamiltonian that we think really
describes the physics of the world it's
a theory um okay yeah I guess I was
going to say Wilson's other great idea
you could cause the ten billion dollar
idea which is that yeah it's true there
are just a few parameters that you have
to keep to describe the monarchy physics
but this condition that the mass of the
theory is small in units of 1 over the
lattice spacing is really unstable you
have to tune the Hamiltonian very
carefully to realize that condition this
isn't any surprise to in dense matter
physicists it means that when there's a
second order phase transition it only
occurs when you tune the parameters just
right it's you know co dimension one say
in some space of parameters but it means
you have to tune the microscopic theory
very well to get this condition that the
mass is small and units one over the
left spacing and that fine tuning from a
fundamental point of view seems very
disgusting and so it led to the
expectation that when the Large Hadron
Collider turned on we find new physics
because according to the standard model
there is a scalar field described by
Hamiltonian kind of like this there's
other stuff in the standard model as
well that's the Higgs field there's a
corresponding particle that expose on we
know that expose on can't be extremely
heavy and so that means somebody kind of
fine tune
Tony to keep the exposé on light and so
the expectation was there had to be some
more fundamental reason why that expose
on turned out to be light and so there
were proposals about what kinds of new
physics would make that natural all of
which seem to suggest there'd be new
particles that would be discovered at
the Large Hadron Collider so where are
they it's a little bit disturbing that
they haven't been seen and maybe when
we're not quite sure what that's telling
us maybe this whole idea of naturalness
that we shouldn't have to fine-tune to
get nature to be the way she is maybe
it's a misguided idea nature does do
some fine-tuning it's kind of a mystery
of course there's another even more
famous fine-tuning which is the dark
energy the energy in the vacuum is
nonzero it's extremely small nobody
knows why it should be so small it seems
to involve tuning nobody understands
that either all right but I'm supposed
to be talking about a quantum algorithm
okay I'm getting there well let me tell
you what it is in our papers which would
have appeared so far that we simulate it
well I already told you we simulated
this theory we simulated it or we didn't
really because we don't have a quantum
computer we describe an algorithm for
simulating it if we had a quantum
computer in spatial i'm going to
sometimes use capital d since that's
what i'm used to which is the space-time
to mention the spatial dimension l plus
1 and we described how you would
simulate this lambda phi for theory the
theory with this type of interaction in
two three and four dimensional
space-time and incidentally when it
comes to taking this limit of going to
the continuum removing lattice spacing
there's an important thing
everybody should know and that is that
in more than four space-time dimensions
the limit seems to be trivial when you
look at the physics in other words and
very long distances compared to the
lattice spacing the interaction goes
away and so you really really just
becomes a theory of free particles so
for this type of quantum field theory it
becomes extremely boring and more than
four space-time dimensions for g equals
four it's kind of a marginal case where
well the same thing probably happens
this we can make mathematically rigorous
that it really becomes a free theory in
more than four dimensions in four
dimensions it probably becomes a free
theory though I don't think there's a
completely a complete mathematical proof
of that from first principles but the
interactions kind of turn off very
slowly as you go to longer and longer
distances but you get interesting
continuum limits and two or three
space-time dimensions and so it may not
be a coincidence that there's something
of a critical importance and quantum
field theory about for space-time
dimensions and we live in four
space-time dimensions um ok so what is
the algorithm supposed to do well of
course you can't read of IQ I sorry you
could have written up by Q yeah well
fine cube theory we thank you know
doesn't have a Hamiltonian which is
bounded from below although it does it
doesn't give had the same problems with
the infrared flow
you know I should have erased the one on
the lab
yeah probably didn't want to erase my
Hamiltonian that's okay alt right right
understood what he meant by but equal
before I think the
might be easier yeah I'm saying that if
you really wanted to simulate the
Hamiltonian evolution in the continuum
limit it simulate the evolution of
states when the relevant physics is all
at arbitrarily long length scales
compared to the lattice spacing it
becomes a very easy problem in more than
four space-time dimensions because it's
just free field theory and we know how
to do that it's a Gaussian theory okay
and so the problem is that these
interactions no longer do anything at
very long distances a kind of a nice way
of thinking about that well I don't
think I have time to explain it but it's
a true fact okay so one way we could
don't describe what we're trying to do
is we and I already sort of said this we
create the vacuum actually I think I'm
going to skip this part let me just make
one comment you know I should have made
it before I said okay quantum simulation
means we prepare a state we evolve and
then we measure but of course the
preparation can be hard we know it was
the subject of the previous talk that
finding the ground state of a
Hamiltonian can be a QM a hard problem
and so that we're talking about state
preparations which we really don't
expect to be able to do on our quantum
computer with reasonable resources but
but it's physicist you know we're not
worried about that because the lesson of
QM a hardness is that there are certain
state preparations that nature can't do
because they're too hard so you know
people who think about spin glasses have
been aware of this for decades that if a
spin glass at low temperature were able
to relax the thermal equilibrium it
would have to solve an np-hard problem
and so what does it mean it means that
it can't relax to equilibrium
you don't think it can solve such
problems so the states that we care
about if our goal is to simulate nature
are the states that can be efficiently
prepared on a general-purpose quantum
computer that's what we think are the
state preparation problems that nature
salts um but I was going to say
something about why I think the problem
that we're solving is b QP hard but let
me skip that and just tell you what what
we did so and obvious that is p QP are
right because we should be able to
encode a quantum circuit using the field
theory but um i'm not going to describe
that so we can think of the problem is
being presented this way we have an
input which is some list of particle
momentum
and what we want to output this is a
list of incoming particle multiplied
whom particles which are going to
collide and we want to output a list of
outgoing particle momentum or momentum
and what we're trying to do is to sample
with reasonable accuracy from the
probability distribution of states that
we can get this is the s-matrix it's
meant to describe what happens as Impala
CLE when you bang some particles
together let's say I have two incoming
particles with a lot of energy they
collide we want to simulate this
collision and it will in general in a
relativistic theory many particles can
be created if it's kinematically
possible so we expect there to be a lot
of relatively soft particles soft
meaning they carry some small fraction
of the incoming total energy and we
would like to simulate the different
possible final states the probability
distribution of final states with some
small error and this is particularly why
would my balls just make a comment about
why we think it's hard in the case where
we're in less than four spatial
dimensions if we try to analyze this
perturbatively in our coupling constant
we'd really be doing an expansion and
lambda over em to the four minus D
lambda is the coupling M is the physical
mass of the particles if this is a
border one then we say that theory is
has strong coupling
it means that if we did try to analyze
the theory in a power series expansion
in lambda it would converge very badly
in fact even if we can sum up the
perturbation theory to all orders we
don't think it gives the exact answer
there are contributions which go like e
to the minus order 1 over lambda that
don't show up in any order of the
perturbation expansion and although we
have you know methods like Fineman
diagram methods and more recent sexier
methods for doing perturbation theory
first of all it doesn't get the exact
answer and secondly even if we did try
to compute to some higher order of
perturbation theory we don't know how to
do that efficiently because summing up
all the terms has a complexity that
scales badly with the order perturbation
theory it's actually worse than
exponential it's like factorial growth
so we don't know how to do a
perturbative study of this type of
process and well I think we can make an
argument that we have not actually
worked that out in all its details that
it speak to be hard because we can
simulate a quantum circuit using the
quantum field theory so the procedure
that we analyzed or at least one of the
procedures that we analyze goes like
this
so we started out by preparing the
vacuum of the free field theory okay at
that for free field the ground side of
the theory one lambda is zero but we're
interested in the interacting theory so
we have to turn on the coupling but
first we prepare wave packets of the
free theory so now we have some wave
packets with pretty well to find
momentum we can't define the momentum
exactly precisely because these wave
packets had some finite spatial spread
but they're narrow in momentum space
they're about to bump into one another
of course in the free theory they just
passed through one another because the
particles don't interact but then we
adiabatically turn on turn on the
coupling so as we do so the idea is that
we transform the particles of the free
theory to what this is sometimes called
the dressed particles of the interacting
theory and then once we have the
interaction turned on we can evolve
using the Hamiltonian for some finite
amount of time until we're ready to read
out the results of the collision and one
way you can do that is to again do an
adiabatic now turn off of the
interaction sending lambda T slowly back
down to zero and then finally readout
measure the field modes to find the
momenta in the final states
and so the question is what are the
sources of error and what can we say
about how big they are which one
dominates actually depends on what
particular problem we study like for
example in one spatial dimension we want
to simulate the scalar field theory but
some of the sources of error we have to
worry about are the land is facing the
fact that it's not really zero or in
other words we're not considering
physical processes at arbitrarily long
distance and lattice units we can only
simulate a finite spatial volume we have
to digitize the fields at least that's
the way we chose to encode the problem
so 5x is really formally a real value
variable but we give it a certain number
of bits of precision and we justify that
using the finite total energy of the
process so we have to estimate how big
an error we're making there but when we
simulate the time evolution as always we
introduce some finite step and do a
Trotter approximation so there's a chair
or due to the Trotter step size and then
there's also what I'll call the diabetic
error that is the deviation from a
perfect ad of participation on and off
and so for example to give you an idea
why do we have to turn off you don't
necessarily have to turn it off but
that's one possible way of doing the
readout and we've actually also analyzed
another way in which we simulate a
particle detector which you know
measures the amount of energy and
momentum deposited in a Cell just kind
of like modeling what a experimental
physicists would do in a scattering
experiment and then that's another way
of sampling from the final stage Tim I
understand the reason you turn it on is
because you won't involve this easily
prepared Vance yeah that's right and so
but what I'm interested in is you know
the particle separate separate from one
another there's going to be some finite
number of particles you know I did
there's something important that I guess
I didn't mention which is well I sort of
mentioned it mate while not really that
I'm going to consider a finite basket so
I want to consider and strictly greater
than zero so with some total amount of
energy know there's some finite number
of particles which were kinematically
allowed to produce and I'd like to read
out what are the particles in the final
state so one way to do that is to turn
off the coupling and then I know exactly
how to measure in each mode whether
there's a particle there or not
otherwise I would have to you know find
some other way of diagnosing what
particles are in the final state yeah ok
so suppose we're doing the case where we
have two spatial dimensions or three
space-time dimensions that's one of the
interesting cases it turns out if I'm
interested in the scaling with the error
what turns out to dominate it is the
step of preparing the free field vacuum
with that's if the preparation of a
Gaussian state so it just means doing
some matrix arithmetic
if the state is Gaussian it means that
if we know its covariance matrix which
is the expectation value in the vacuum
of a product of two of the field
variables that completely characterizes
the state and free field theory we know
what this covariance is and we just have
to construct the chorus pinned
corresponding Gaussian State there's an
algorithm for constructing Gaussian
States on a quantum computer the most
efficient one that I know is due to
Kataya and web but it really just
requires that we multiply some matrices
together using our quantum computer and
what I won't explain the details of that
but because it's limited by how fast we
can do matrix multiplication its
complexity as impala cailli scales like
the best currently known algorithms for
doing matrix arithmetic and so
neglecting algorithms sorry neglecting
logarithms I think those words mixed up
a lot neglecting logarithms it goes like
the number of qubits which I'm denoting
whatever this letter is script d to the
2.3 73 that comes from the complexity of
doing matrix arithmetic and this is the
number of qubits in our quantum computer
it goes like the physical volume the
volume that we're trying to simulate in
lattice units 0 divided by a to the
little d a the lattice spacing d the
spatial dimension ality and so now I
want to get a sufficiently small error
getting a small error means that the
lattice spacing has to be small in
physical units so we have to figure out
how the error scales with the lattice
spacing and the answer is
that the error goes like a power the
lattice spacing it goes like lettuce
spacing squared and so those are
corrections to that arise from the fact
that we should be studying the theory in
continuous space but we're studying it
on the lettuce instead and so this error
scales in the case of this is D equals
to this goes like so this is the thing
that gets raised to the 2 point 3 73
power and this is a 1 over a squared
that means 1 over epsilon so it's going
like 1 over epsilon to this power and
that's the least favorable scaling with
epsilon of all of these steps so in this
case it tells us how the number of gates
that we need and the number of qubits
scales with the error now I also have to
worry about how things scale with the
energy and and this also is a little
disappointing it's polynomial scaling so
hooray but it's not such a great
polynomial the number of gates that we
need to do our simulation to some fixed
accuracy scales like and the total
energy of the process to the sixth power
it turns out there's one power of energy
from making the trotter they are small
how big the trotter air is actually
depends on how excited the fields can
get and that's controlled by the total
energy in the process and then there's a
factor of e squared and that comes from
the fact that we need the lattice
spacing to get smaller as the energy
gets larger in order to simulate very
short wavelength excitation sufficiently
currently so making the higher energy
means smaller lattice spacing that means
more cubits in the computer that means
more gates and then there's a factor of
e cubed which comes from the analysis of
the diabetic error the fact that
excitations can be created while
returning the Hamiltonian on and off and
so this it's a little harder to explain
why it C cubed I'll just say what goes
into that analysis there are two things
that we have to worry about when we're
turning the coupling on or off it could
be that we excite particles out of the
vacuum normally particles wouldn't
spontaneously appear but if we're
driving the system by changing the
Hamiltonian as a function of time there
are processes in which the mass term and
our amal Tony and can create a pair of
particles or our interaction term can
create four particles and what's
controlling how often that happens is
the mascot so this is where it's really
important that we're simulating a theory
which has a nonzero mass and there's
another process that we have to worry
about witches particles can split one
particle can split into three I
described by this interaction if the
particles were massless that would
actually be kinematically allowed one
particle can split into three particles
which are all moving in the same
direction whose momentum adds up to of
the original particle so when we go into
sufficiently high energy this becomes
more and more of a problem in the limit
of energy very large compared to mass
this splitting can occur there's some
energy gap for that non adiabatic
process but the gap actually goes away
as the energy gets high gap goes like M
squared over eve
for large energy so this actually turns
out to be the more vexing problem if
we're studying the scaling with energy
and that's where this it turns out this
e cubed comes from so um so one can
successfully show in this case of a
scalar theory with an interaction as a
mask at that we can do the simulation
with resources that scale polynomial e
but they're not very nice polynomial so
scaling with both the error and with the
energy are not so good so that raises
the question of whether we can do much
better and in principle we probably
could do considerably better of what we
would need to I mean I should emphasize
that although there's been some recent
progress and improving how resources
scale with the trotter error that's not
really our problem here the problem is
that we have this spatial lattice and
the problem is that we need to make the
lattice spacing small in the units that
are relevant to the physics that we're
trying to simulate in order to have a
small error small lattice spacing means
more cubits and more gates and so the
way to make things better is to choose
our Hamiltonian more cleverly it's what
physicists would call a renormalization
group improvement to the Hamiltonian we
would add additional terms which would
allow us to simulate physics which looks
like continuum physics without making
the lattice spacing so small but that
isn't something that we've tried to
systematically analyzed to see how much
we can improve the resource costs so let
me just say no more the overtime so
quickly some of the things that some
other things that we've done and some
things that we have not done so we
analyze the simulation of fermionic
theories we've analyzed an alternative
algorithm
which has some advantages in which
instead of turning on the interaction
when after creating the wave packets we
turn on the interaction to create the
vacuum of the interacting theory and
then excite particles by turning on time
and spatially modulated sources and that
has a big advantage because there can be
level crossings in the excited state
spectrum that would cause a bad diabetic
error if for example there are bound
states in the theory which are stable
particles such crossings occur so if we
really wanted to simulate a theory with
bound States we should do something
different and so there's an alternative
that we've worked out i mentioned b QP
hardness and passing that's something
that we sort of have a strategy to show
that this simulation problem is b QP
hard though we haven't worked out all
the details some other things which it's
exactly is it's not as clear how to
proceed although we have rough ideas
what about the case where we're trying
to simulate a theory with massless
particles I think the key there is to
get the physics right you can't expect
to say adiabatic ly turn on the
interaction without creating lots of
particles if there's no energy gap but
on the other hand that can be relatively
harmless if these are very soft very
long wavelengths particles and we could
still get good simulations of the right
physics questions to ask which are what
happens when you scatter two particles
where each particle is surrounded by a
cloud of very soft massless particles
because that's what would really happen
in a physics experiment and I another
thing that we have only a vague idea
about is simulating gauge theories which
is what women would really like to do to
describe the fundamental particle
physics and real world and ultimately I
would like to understand whether it's
possible to efficiently
la quantum gravity and they're sort of
our do I mean there's a strategy there
but it's a little bit more distant I
think it's an it's distant but in a
conceptually interesting why I hope that
you know just like Wilson found an
answer to the question what is quantum
field theory by thinking about how to
put quantum field theory on a computer
we can gain insight into what is
strength area what is quantum gravity by
thinking about how we would simulate it
on a quantum computer so that's the
story for now thanks
well I mean I yeah I think in the case
of the two-dimensional to spatial
dimension Theory where you know I'm like
I don't want to talk about three spatial
dimensions where in the continual one
that it's trivial and in one spatial
dimension it's you know less obvious
about how hard it is in two spatial
dimensions it's a super normalizable
theory and so that has some nice
features but you still can't do
perturbation theory in this strong
coupling regime even in the two spatial
dimensions a theory and I'm a don't
think there are any known classical
methods for studying the real time
evolution of the theory in the strong
coupling machine and beyond that I think
that we should be able by considering a
suitable formulation of the problem to
show that it's a b QP hard problem by
simulating a quantum circuit through no
particle interactions
yeah so that's right I would define it
in a somewhat different way but i would
consider this formulation of the problem
i would say okay let's prepare the
vacuum and now let's consider a
hamiltonian in which i turn on now i'm
going to integrate over space-time so
then it's not hamiltonian i guess i
better not do that ok I'll integrate
over space and then I'll have some
sources which are classical and some
local operators which are operators of
the quantum field theory so this is
something classical that we can control
and this is a quantum field theory
operator and so now the resources will
be um you know have something to do with
the you know the Fourier decomposition
of these classical sources which
corresponds to the energy and the
scattering process that I occurred that
I described before and the the
space-time volume that we want to
simulate and then in the end again will
read out values of some local operators
the task will be to you know simulate
accurately the probability distribution
of those outcomes and then in that
setting we can imagine encoding qubits
say by using the sources to turn on
potential wells in which we can hold
particles in which we could do single
qubit gates say by changing the height
of one potential well compared to
another bringing two wells together
getting some phase shift to occur so we
could do to cupid gates and you know
simulate some Universal set of gates
using the field theory in the case where
we have time-dependent classical sources
that's the idea
what was it
wasn't expected that you would get a gap
when you visited there anybody
you know what's that a surprise it was
is that something
was what something I expected you know
it doesn't said there was ten we just
got how'd he do analysis of the diabetic
erin was what's that expected yeah I
don't really think there were any
surprises and the story other I mean but
when we started we didn't know you know
exactly what scaling we would get and
this isn't some you know scaling with
energy that first of all I have no
particular reason to think that it's
optimal but until we did the analysis we
didn't know exactly what scaling to
expect though we expected it to be
polynomial what about one of these
grassman if they're posted grass 9am
people talk about things like I
assimilating attitudes is that you know
how competitive it is with this right so
I saw that end up making reference to
recent advances in formulating quantum
field theory in a new way which makes it
possible to in a much more efficient way
as sum up all the contributions to
perturbation theory in a given order but
as far as as far as i know the
complexity of doing such computations to
order n still scaled super polynomial e
NN in that formulation despite the
dramatic improvements over previous
methods
okay so sorry to keep you waiting long
time but in order to the privilege to
have Jordan frost kill one of the
pillars of the fields cap off the wood
car